this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to being well i'm george
campbell your host joined today by dr
john deloney and we're excited to take
your calls about life money
relationships boundaries career you name
it we are here for you to help you take
that right next step the number to call
is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five michelle kicks us off
she's in kalamazoo michelle welcome to
the show
thank you
absolutely how can john and i help
um i have a question on i have 54 000 in
student loan debt
um i stopped paying on student loans
when
you know everything happened a couple
years ago um
my payment was 687 a month and now i'm
realizing i probably should have
continued to pay that since there was no
interest it would all go towards
principal
i have approximately nine thousand
dollars in my savings account which
is kind of like emergency money um
and i'm just curious if i should
take out a chunk of that money to start
paying down on that should i just start
up my regular payments um what should i
do to tackle that
all of it so michelle what's your income
uh 60 000. cool
okay and what's uh what kind of work are
you in
um i'm an occupational therapist awesome
good for you and is this 9 000 is that
all the money you have to your name
that's liquid
um
that's liquid yes okay
so
what we teach baby step one thousand
dollar starter emergency fund and
everything else
is going to go towards the debt which
means 8 000 of your 9 000 goes towards
the debt does that scare you a little
bit
a little bit
good that's exactly what i want i kind
of want you to not be comfortable for a
short period of time
so i want you to start doing the math
and go okay 54 000 i make 60k can i do
overtime can i do some side hustles can
i get rid of this debt
in the next two years do you think you
can do that
i think i could
michelle
how
60 000 for an occupational therapist
feels low to me are you at a place that
you just love or are you being underpaid
dramatically for the market well
i do work with kids so that does pay a
little bit lower and i'm in a highly ot
populated area
so
i could pick up something with adults
like as a prn weekend yep type thing um
in order to increase that
i would love like following george i
would love to that angst you feel like
you're gonna feel super exposed like you
are sitting on a
sidewalk in a major intersection and you
just got like a a hand towel covering
your you up right you're gonna feel like
that with a thousand emergency fund i
want you to channel that angst into i'm
gonna work seven days a week for the
next 24 months and be done forever you
know what i mean i'm just gonna change
all of this yeah michelle if i showed up
at your door every single month with 700
cash
just for fun would you be stoked
definitely well that's what you get to
do for yourself when you pay these
student loans off and then think about
what would i want to do with that 700
extra month
do i want to invest it do i want to save
do i want to finally go on that trip
because right now i feel like you've
just been in this limbo of like well
we'll see what happens and student loan
forgiveness and there's no interest but
like you mentioned right now is when you
actually feel the progress
where the loans aren't continuing to
accrue interest and build and build and
go wait it was 54 now it's 58 i'll never
get through this
and so i want you to take advantage of
this time to make that progress and if
that means getting the side job getting
a different job doing whatever it takes
slashing expenses i'm totally good with
that
okay so pay the 8 000 like 8 000 of it
off and then start doing those actual
payments per month absolutely what was
the tote what was the total
687 a month
oh so it's 54. okay
here's here's how when i i had six
figures student loans had a lot i got 28
degrees and a lot of loans
the way i got through it was the rule of
tens in the front so all i wanted to do
was whatever it took to get that front
number to be one lower so today you're
going to have a psychological victory
because you owe
55 000
and then right after this call you're
gonna go hit a couple of buttons on your
computer and that first number is going
to be a four now
and then you can say okay how crazy can
i be in the next 90 days and get that
sucker down to a three in front right
and i'm just gonna i'm gonna drill on
that front number and that that's how i
keep going when i've got had such a big
number is i want to just drop that front
number drop that front number about to
do our mortgage and it feels so good
like all right we just got another
number down right so it feels good to
keep keep plugging along that way are
you doing an every dollar budget
currently michelle
um i'm trying to no there is no try yoda
said okay i'm not i'm not can we help
you try can i gift you every dollar
premium to help you it'll track your
transactions connect to your bank and
make it even easier to stick to it
yes that would be awesome thank you that
is my gift to you to give you a push on
this journey it also includes financial
peace university and big news john we
just added new videos with john and i
for the first time ever we are now
inside of financial peace university
so you can go check out that why
spending lesson to help you in that area
and on top of that it's all inside of
ramsay plus so there's coaching in there
for help along the way with our team and
a ton of tools and resources so that'll
be our gift to you michelle would you
call us back when you're debt free
i definitely will we'd love to hear it
thank you so much i appreciate it yes
we're cheering you on this is a big one
john you and i both had student loans
you had way more because you're way
smarter than me uh i don't think it's
nice that's how it works i mean you have
multiple phds i set in more classes
rooms than you did yeah they accrued
more i have a bachelor of science and
communication yes and i'm using that
degree john i'll have you know you're
communicating right now we both are
using our degrees i'm proud of us and by
the way
you mentioned something to
to michelle you said if i just showed up
at your house
every month i mean every once a month
we should show up at my house once a
month george it'd be great you don't
have to bring 700 you can just show up
and hang out i don't even have your
address john you live that far off the
grid do you even have an address i do
not it's just like take a right when you
see the big oak tree with the mark on it
it's one of those you'll never find dr
john you you don't say that because
there's some there's i challenge you
guys to find no please don't do that
yeah you probably want to do that oh
that's good times because i'm waiting
for you yes so i graduated with about 36
000 in student loan debt i thought my
parents were rich because my dad was
like ah we got it taken care of what i
didn't know was that was just meant he's
gonna help me sign up for the loans that
was nice
very kind of him and so i graduated
going oh i got to pay this back now
that's how this works and oh here's the
monthly i didn't understand what the
monthly payment was going to be oh this
is how much i know i had to pay it back
i
i just didn't understand what that meant
what that felt like in your actual
reality i thought when i got my job i
would get
all this money and all of this money
would give me a house and a car and food
and because you deserve it john
love america and i thought i was just
gonna have all this
and it was like no that's 800 a month or
2000 or whatever the number ended up
being
i thought oh i can't do any of this
other stuff and they're like yep keep
paying you know i mean i didn't know
what it meant but uh it's good here we
are today 1.7 trillion dollars 45
million americans buried under this
thing the new american dream is to now
be debt-free and not have student loan
debt can you imagine uh
all we're trying to do is get america to
zero that's it
just a baseline foundational but that's
what we're here to do we want to help
you win
your life your money your career your
mental health we're here for you triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
deloney best-selling author and host of
the dr john deloney show i host the fine
print podcast as well as the entree
leadership podcast all of which you can
find on the ramsay network or wherever
you listen to podcasts open phones this
hour triple eight eight two 825-5225
fred joins us up next in bristol vermont
fred welcome to the show
hey guys thanks for having me absolutely
um i have a question um so
um my wife and i currently own
about 80 000 left on our mortgage and um
and
my wife and i have a disagreement about
uh whether or not we should pay off the
house
or
invest the money that we make uh at a
you know higher rate than 15
of our income um and
uh it's it's like
the
we would benefit from the tax uh from
the tax for tax purposes for the um uh
for not being in such a higher tax
bracket um if we can hide the income in
our iras or uh 401ks uh
so i just wonder what your thoughts are
on that i'd like to pay off the house
how much how much do you make
um we make about 250 000 combined okay
so you're pretty close to that here's
the thing um pay the house off
pay the house off yeah um because you're
holding a liability
and basically you're trying to build a
house on a teeter-totter okay
and you're holding a liability that's
gonna be constant whether your income
goes away suddenly whether the market
over six months drops 15 to 20 which it
has right i think so
i love the idea of investing and dumping
all this money into iras and stuff but
don't do it on a teeter-totter right on
this
reflect on this liability so and i get
her well she's doing his math right
she's just doing the math and i think i
could make this
well yeah but it's it's
i'm paying two percent interest right
now on our mortgage and i think i can
earn eight percent on the market and so
i'm leaving six percent on the table
that math i get that but that's not how
risk works right
well she also wants to she doesn't want
to be put in a higher tax bracket and i
don't really know what the i really
don't know what to do
what do you mean a higher tax bracket
how is paying off your mortgage you're
gonna put you in a higher tax bracket
well if we if we use the money if we
hide our income in an ira or there's no
hiding you're not hiding income this
isn't a life hack
yeah you're not hiding it you're okay
you're trying to find write-offs
are you talking about writing off your
mortgage you're saying
the interest deduction on your taxes
from paying the mortgage right
yes and and not in not showing as much
income through our because we pre-tax
our
contributions to our ras and 401ks yes
you're not hiding money they're not like
what we thought you made 48 000 a year
we had no idea you made 250. it's not
like that it's it does affect the amount
of
of taxable income you have but you're
not hiding it from anybody i don't off
george you may know i don't know if top
my head how that works with brackets
well the brackets don't just make you
pay that much more in taxes it's that
much graded up right so if you're a
thousand dollars over into the next
bracket you're not now paying 27 percent
on all of your income you're only paying
that 27 percent on the thousand right so
it's not going to affect your life all
that much now let me talk about the tax
deduction because this one really grinds
my gears john
here's what happens
let's say you pay 10 000 in interest on
your mortgage right
and now you get to deduct that so you
call that a huge win
now when it comes time to tax time what
that really amounts to is about 2500 of
tax burdens that you saved right
you following me
because you're not paying 10 000 less in
taxes the government just sees that you
made 10 000 less in income therefore it
changes so if you have 25 tax bracket
you're paying 2 500 bucks
on that money so basically here's what
we're seeing you send us 10 000 to the
lender and no to me and george
personally
and we guarantee you
because we love you we're gonna send you
two thousand five hundred dollars in
savings
okay see what see what we're doing there
what it is is you're trading a dollar
for a quarter because you're going to
send 10 000 to the lender in interest
so that you can get 2500
from the government
in savings i would rather have
send nothing to the mortgage and pay my
2 500 bucks every year and also you can
only do that now if you're itemizing it
doesn't work with standard deduction
and also if you have roth you can't
deduct that either so i you mentioned
401ks and iras roth is after tax so
you're not going to get that deducted
right so there's a lot of bad reasons to
keep a mortgage
and there's very few good ones and
what's your mortgage payment right now
uh 850 a month okay
so take that amount back into your
budget every month do all the math on
how much interest you're paying
start to have a vision for what that
future looks like and i think your wife
will go okay fine
because if she wants to do math hey
let's dance but you're gonna have to do
the math back and go that doesn't work
that's not how that works we're not
hiding money this isn't a life hack and
if you pay that sucker off it's like an
eight thousand dollar raise
right right annually just just just by
paying your house off do you all have
the cash to pay it off
um we don't have like liquid right right
away i mean probably have you know we
could probably half of it uh in liquid
cash right now but
um
but we you know we have
we just don't have enough to just boom
take care of it oh you have you have
that much liquid cash over and above
your emergency fund
or that is your emergency yes we do okay
well no we've got an emergency fund um
but we could we could take money in the
bank and pay pass the mortgage so
like george just walked you through the
math part i walked you through the risk
and leverage part here's the the
the most honest answer george and i can
both give you
that when we fully funded our emergency
funds all the rest of that money went to
our mortgages
okay does that make sense so i'm just
telling you like yeah what i do in my
house me and my wife and my kids do and
i can give you all the theories all day
long and play math with you i'm just
telling you here's what i do in my house
is i dump every extra
all of our extra money
onto a mortgage and george george just
paid his off and so that's just how we
live our life i like to keep those
accounts separate too because all of a
sudden the emergency fund you've got all
this extra cash in there and it gets a
little bit squishy as to what this
money's really for so keep the emergency
fund separate you can have a separate
account if you want to save up and throw
that on the house but i just did it out
of every paycheck every time i got a
paycheck i went great this is all gravy
i'm throwing it at the mortgage and we
did it in 26 months and i don't regret
it and i don't miss the tax deduction i
can tell you that much okay
yeah okay go be free man go be free
thank you yeah okay i appreciate you
guys taking my call absolutely man hey
when you tell your wife tell her
specifically george said she was wrong
oh boy not me that was true john is a
saint i can do no wrong
no america love john hey thanks so much
for the call fred appreciate you man
good stuff so uh we got big news john
big news for america what is it you
don't even know no one tells john
anything around here we are super
excited to announce so true our team
just launched some incredible updates to
financial peace university i know that
you and i are in it okay hey relax man
i'm just raising the news i'm excited
about it i'm just reading the news
this is still the same timeless plan and
principles we always teach but now
there's brand new content to help you
stay in control of your money and the
two of us are extra excited because we
are in the course now we made it inside
the matrix john i know i looked at the
cover today and i went we did it mom
can you believe it i never thought i
mean financial peace university is a
thing that changed my life back in 2013
and so now to be a part of that i just
i'm pinching myself just such an honor
so if you uh john i know you you worked
real hard on your talk for this in why
spending we kind of we co-taught this
course and really brought a lot of fresh
life to it you with a lot of the
psychology of spending about how
how companies go after our brains yeah
and i kind of covered here's how they're
going after your wallet right thanks to
how they're going after your brains
so it's a really really strong course
really proud of the work we did there i
also covered baby step three in the
emergency fund and you know try to bring
some life to that bring some jokes to it
i don't know if they're funny they
weren't in the crowd so hopefully people
watching at home think they're funnier
so here's the deal
behind stage i felt those laughters john
thank you so here's the deal if you're
already a ramsay plus member you can log
in right now and check out that new
content and here's the better news if
you've never given financial peace
university a shot now's the time you can
get started at a special price of just
99 bucks for one year of access to fbu
and all of the extra perks inside of
ramsay plus just go to fpu.com
and check it out let us know what you
think incredible reverse inflation
that's how that works instead of getting
more expensive we put out something
brand new and we lowered the price
blessed to be a blessing
that's what we say around here i like
that so check it out send john some hate
mail send me all the love fpu.com we'll
be back with you this is the ramsey show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
you're listening to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print and entree
leadership podcast joined today
by the host of the dr john deloney show
you guessed it it's dr john dolone
himself and your best friend
yes that too no
we're trying to convince america that
john likes me and so this is his attempt
no i i've been trying to invited me over
your house already this hour i've tried
to be your best friend best friend yeah
fine
you win john we're in you win yep we're
best friends now it's huge it's that
easy to go you want to go do karate in
the garage no absolutely not oh man then
we're not best friends
that was a movie reference for those of
you wondering john doesn't actually do
karate in his garage i literally
actually do crowded my garage doesn't
shock me it's a whole other conversation
well this is about you america not about
john and our friendship so give us a
call and make this stop triple eight
eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five mario
who's our new friend he's in houston
he's on the line welcome to the show man
hey hi guys
um i have a my family crisis and kind of
a financial crisis as a result i uh just
broke up with my fiance and she moved
out
um sorry
recently
i'm sorry again i'm so sorry to hear
that yeah man oh yeah thank you
um we just recently built a new house
that's 700 000
and it's got a 350 000 mortgage no
no
and if we sell right now it's at least a
50 000 loss based on all the realtors
um my thought is if i buy her out her
portion and take on the 350 000 mortgage
between myself and my mom i have 350 000
in cash
do i pay down some of that mortgage with
that do i even do this do i even take
this house
um so that we don't lose the 50 000. it
feels like there's some sun cost fallacy
happening dude i would sell the house
well you're hanging on to this thing but
it's going to be a curse more than it's
going to be a blessing mario you're
going to listen you're going to you're
going to
mess up your relationship with your mom
with the money this everything changes
when you owe your parent money
and
you're going to have to figure out you
have to get with attorneys and figure
out what's the buyout fee and are we
going to get this all signed off so i'm
going to pay dude i would take the hit
and sell the house and don't buy a house
with somebody you're not married to
moving forward just because it's so
complicated to unwind at all
uh is she
is she is her is her name on the lease
or i mean on the mortgage
yes and on the title yeah okay so you're
gonna have to refinance this thing
anyways i don't know that the bank's
gonna allow you to refinance on your own
can you afford this yeah if he comes to
350 grand
but what what's your buyout going to be
175
her but her buyout would be about 125
000. how do you figure
because you already have how much she
put in oh okay all right
then who's going to pay for the loss
yeah that makes you slowly responsible
for the loss i would be the fully
responsible and i'm i'm willing to do
that because i don't want her to lose
the money
she's got less money to begin with and i
don't want to have to take it on i'm
willing to live in the house for a year
or two and sell it
at that point the price
would hopefully not go down on the value
of the home it's a new build it's a
brand new house there's um it's just
that right and the actual base value of
the house from the same builder has gone
up in price
but because there are no recent sales
the realtors are telling me you're gonna
max out at seven hundred thousand at
best and you know when you do that
you're paying them fifty thousand for
the sale so it's a fifty thousand dollar
loss at least
and i could cover the mortgage if i if i
needed to it'd be fifty percent of my
pay ouch as is hey liz mario mario mario
yeah you're trying to make this work man
you've had a lot of loss
my guess is this breakup with the fiance
has been sometime coming which means
you've been living in chaos for a season
is that fair
a little bit yeah i mean the other
issue is that if i move out now i'm
having to find an apartment and the
apartment prices are fairly high as well
the cost of the apartment is going to be
effectively the same
if maybe a little bit more if i just
was able to pay down the mortgage itself
my mom is living with me anyway yeah so
and
between us we can cover
at least a majority of the mortgage and
i'm not saying put everything in it just
because i need to have some money saved
maybe a hundred thousand so have a
hundred thousand dollar mortgage as a
result so here's the thing you've got a
plan yeah you've got a plan you're
clearly a smart guy you got a plan um
and so you're gonna do what you're gonna
do
i'm telling you
if i was in your exact shoes i'm from
houston if i had woke up in houston and
yours i got engaged in houston so if me
and the person who's my wife now if we'd
broken up i would have sold the house
and taken the hit moved on with moved
into an apartment paid a lot of money
and unshackled myself from what was to
begin playing for what will be
you are hoping you are taking 50 percent
of your take-home income carrying your
mom on a house note on a prayer
that the next two years
the economy pumps the house back up
i don't know if you've watched the news
but the next two years look like it's
gonna be a little bit of a rough ride
i would i mean george hopping i would
not be looking for the next 24 months
for things to just go through the roof
now i'd be out to lunch on that but i
would take the hit and walk away that's
what i would do now if you move to an
apartment you'd mom would be with you
right
yeah and so you'd be splitting that rent
i think you can find a place that's not
50 of your
pay
with mom to rent for a while until we
figure out what's next because it sounds
like you don't need a house this big
anyways
uh i don't but now we're going to a
house the third apartment the third the
size
that's right hey brother that's ego
multiple situations and a mental thing
you know what i mean i know mario
because you had plans in your life and
those plans are different now
and
there
there's a move in mixed martial arts
that we used to practice and that is it
sometimes you find yourself in a bad
position up against the cage up against
the the ropes right
and you literally can't get out you're
stuck
and so we used to drill over and over
how to ride the round out
because there is no offense happening
here you got to stare curled up in a
ball you got somebody on top of you
raining down punches here i just gotta
i've got to finagle and take this for
this season until the bell rings i can
get up and reset
that's where you are you broke up with
your fiance your bought a 700 000 house
with a girlfriend
it's gonna it's already gonna cost you
money to get out of it it's gonna cost
you half your life to stay in it you
just gotta turtle up and say okay we're
gonna go to apartment we're gonna retool
and then we're gonna take the next 24
months to figure out what comes next and
it feels like a step back it's not man
this is you protecting yourself and
protecting your mom and protecting your
future and making wise decisions when
things are crazy
yeah have you talked to your mom about
this
yeah what does she think just curious
well she wants to be able to help me and
she thinks she's
better just to pay down the mortgage
keep this house
and so later i can always get a roommate
or another roommate student or somebody
to come in
from my work that could be
helping pay down some of the mortgage
and
we've had the problem you know she's had
money in the bank from a home sale that
hasn't been earning squat
and so has she been saving for
retirement or she retired
yeah she's retired are you her
retirement plan basically yes
your your you or her retirement plan
yeah dude don't sink what little cash
she has left into
this whole don't do that man
yeah
i know it's listen i i absolutely
understand both george we're not trying
to minimize this dude this is hard it's
hard i hear it on you it's hard man
it's the reality of the situation
i'm trying to make you know i
i i want my ex-fiance to not have to be
screwed either that's the thing that's
true i got you but hey
once the relationship is split now this
is a business transaction because we
made a business deal together it felt
like love at the time but it was a
business deal and now that we're split
this is a business proposition so it may
be that she takes 25 000 of the 50 000
loss
or
whenever it gets split out you take what
you put in she takes what she put in all
that this was the decision you guys made
together which means all the risk is on
both of you it's not just on you so i
don't want you to try to be a hero here
and roll over and have it be a giant
financial predicament you're not being
unkind by saying hey we're going to
split the losses because that's what
we're doing in this relationship i'll
take 60 40 here i broke up with you you
still love me we're going to sell this
house whatever we got to do
um and it may be that you go back and
talk to the builder
who's got somebody else lined up and
they're about to put a shovel in the
ground without a real estate agent and
you go to the builder and say hey i've
got my life just blew up um do you have
somebody else in the line that'd be
interested in this house because i don't
lose fifty thousand dollars maybe i can
lose twenty five maybe lose ten and
maybe you can walk away that way
but if i'm you brother i'm still in the
house yeah absolutely sorry man this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
i'm george campbell to my right dr john
deloney you're listening to the ramsay
show give us a call triple eight eight
two five
two
glenn joins us up next in kansas city
glenn welcome to the show
oh thank you uh thanks for taking my
call george happy to do it what's going
on
oh uh you can label me tentative to
retire i like that so
i just need a third-party opinion and
you know i work with a financial advisor
i do i do way too much reading but i
just wanted to run through my scenario
and see if you guys think
do i need to keep working in this
economy or you know can i pull the plug
at 59 and a half okay
just make sure you pull the right plug
yeah
yeah no not the not the life support yes
keep that we want that one in the wall
brother
so hit us with the numbers
okay so um i'm about eighty percent tax
deferred
twenty percent roth um i've got
by the time i retire i imagine i'll have
about 1.5 million
um
and of that 1.5 i'd have about 90 000
cash
i planned on waiting to collect social
security until i'm 70.
my wife is going to continue to work
until i'm 62.
so then you know so i was going to try
to spend down cash in the first couple
of years and then work on the
tax deferred money and try to stay under
80 000 a year
total tax commitment
okay our total income
so you're going am i ready to do this
when when's your plan to do this to
actually retire
currently uh 13 months three days uh 36
minutes something like that wow
what do you do for a living
um i'm a power plant manager okay cool
so what's your current income
about 150 all right and you're not
looking to replace all of that 150 in
retirement
now right now i
i only come home with about half of my
income i put quite a bit into my ross
and
savings account so i could live off 80.
and you'd be happy because that's really
what it comes down to is what's your
picture of retirement and do the numbers
match up to that picture
okay i'm speaking for myself i'd be
happy i don't know if my wife would be
happy
what does she think about all this does
it make her nervous for you to quit
working
absolutely yeah she that's why she wants
to keep working she works remote and we
want to relocate
so i have no interest in paying down my
mortgage i always overpay
but i'm going to take the equity out of
this home and and put it in another home
where we relocate
so here but yes she's nervous here's a
couple of things that i've i would do if
i'm in your shoes and i'll let george
obviously he's way smarter with the with
the numbers side
before i quit
uh before i retired is a nice way to say
that i would take my wife on a retreat
of some sort go out for a day or two
and
literally spend a couple of hours being
highly intentional about telling old
stories what are some things in our
marriage that we loved some of the
adventures we've had our kids some of
the stuff we've been great i talk about
some stuff has been hard
and then i would
shift the conversation and this might
take half a day and i would talk to her
about this before you do it and you
spend some time by yourself and heard
some time by yourself
what do we imagine the next potentially
40 years to be like
we often think like oh it's i'm gonna
i'm gonna retire at 60 and
you might be 40 years my man okay 30
years what do you want that to look like
to george's point if you both don't have
a unified picture of what retirement
looks like or the next phase of your
life is going to look like
you're going to run into a brick wall
and what we're going to do is we're
going to blame that that crash on money
we're going to blame that crash on my
wife she's going to blame that on my
husband's just sitting around the house
but all of that is tied into we were not
unified in where we were headed when we
started off on this new journey the
second thing that's important is you
need to know the research on people who
just up and retire is not great
they fall apart
and so you've done the math what i want
you to begin to consider is man maybe
you're done at 60 work managing a power
plant we want to get out of this town
we've got the state we want to go
somewhere different somewhere hotter
somewhere cooler whatever we're gonna
buy a new house i want you to imagine
it doesn't have to be a job but i'm
gonna volunteer at i'm gonna get really
involved in local whatever i am going to
start bagging groceries i want you to
have a thing that you go to
not that you go from um just the data on
it is the data has convinced me that i
retirement is no longer a thing i'm
interested in
spending money and
building wealth those are things i'm all
excited about but not having something
that i get up and go to every day is
something i'm no longer interested in
solely based on the psychological data
okay so that that's where i would tell
you when you when you're having the
conversation should i retire and then
the number comes in here uh george with
with actual data yeah so glenn you said
you'd have about 1.5 million
in 13 months yeah and that's if the
market bounces back
no that's uh taking in the losses that i
expect
okay do you really want out of this
thing huh
well
it's and it there's i mean she just
wants me to be happy and i do have a
strategy
an exit strategy and it's going to be
working with my kids
so both my kids live in another state
and i really enjoy doing things for them
so i think that's what's really going to
make me happy so i'm not worried about
myself
i think my wife is worried about getting
her nails done and getting her hair done
and i'm a pretty tight individual when
it comes to spending money
um and your wife is saying i don't want
my life to suck for the next 30 years
because glenn retired too because glenn
didn't want to work right
exactly so we've got to take that into
account that's hey that's a
don't be dismissive of that okay i know
it can be annoying like you mean i've
got to work so you can get yes that's
exactly what that means because you all
are a team right so let's have that
conversation
so glenn you've heard of the trinity
study
no
you said you read a lot so i figured but
basically
it i've never heard of it the study
shows that a safe withdrawal rate you
know if you take out four percent uh
from your nest egg every year then the
money will not run out it will continue
to you know outpace if the market's at
eight ten twelve percent you will
continue to have your principal amount
in there which means when you croak
you'd still have 1.5 million
ideally right and so i would start to
look at that
with your with your financial advisor
so
uh we've done cash flow thing and and
the four percent rule is not really
something uh i guess i've looked at it
that way but every online calculator
shows that there's no way you can retire
uh so that's what i keep seeing so but
he says i'm good to go um but
i guess the financial advisor says yeah
your plan checks out
yeah
and that's if you're withdrawing what
seventy thousand a year into retirement
now that was an extra that was like at a
120
wow that feels hot
yeah then that's kind of why i
but that was covering insurance and
other things too okay and since i don't
have to uh you know i back it back down
that's just a larger percentage of the
of the 1.5 million you're looking more
like uh eight percent withdrawal rate at
that point
exactly because then you got that
money's going to run out then you know
in the next few decades
and so just take that into account i
would still run the numbers you
mentioned take waiting to take social
security you might be better off taking
it sooner and investing that money
and so i i'd still run some numbers i'm
going to give you some homework there to
work out with your financial advisor i'm
not saying you can't do it i just want
you to get a real clear picture of what
your lifestyle is going to look like in
retirement where you guys want to go and
i'd also encourage you to go into
retirement without a mortgage payment
you mentioned that you're hanging on to
the mortgage
you're paying a little bit extra i want
that thing to be gone before glenn says
i'm done working i think that will give
your wife some peace of mind as well
yeah the fewer liabilities you take into
a no work
season of your life the better and even
if you think i can invest this the
difference between my three percent
mortgage and that i get all that
but we're just talking about risk and
liability and when you look at your wife
and say we owe no body anything
and here's what we're gonna do that's a
different conversation i'm just talking
about neurological safety brain safety
changes the way you make it brain goes
okay so if the worst case scenario
happens we're still sitting in the same
house because we own it it's ours right
and we just got to scrounge up enough
nickels to pay the taxes every year on
it that's different than we no we're
gonna be homeless what's left on the
mortgage glenn
about 280 okay
yeah i don't want to be taking that when
i retire in 13 months and still have
payments on 280 000 worth of loans so
i'd also look into getting rid of that
or downsizing pay cash for your next
place and then i'll feel real good about
this retirement plan let's have a
conversation as a couple what do we want
this thing to look like to make it a two
day retreat enjoy one another have a
good time but let's get some real
concrete pictures absolutely that puts
this hour of the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to being well i'm george
campbell your host joined today by dr
john deloney and we are pumped to take
your call america the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we're pumped pumped pumped i don't use
that word enough john you should you
gotta bring that back it's time hans and
franz we're going to pump you up we're
ready i'm also from boston so sometimes
i'll slip in wicked it's wicked sick
ps go celtics go celtics i watch the
game for like four minutes and i feel
like i'm a fan now you're back on the
way back on it man
back in it people love to talk to me
about sports so don't call in and talk
about sports we're here to help you with
money with your mental health your
relationships boundaries your life that
we have some expertise in and we're
pumped and we are pumped to take the
call marquita kicks us off in charlotte
north carolina marquita welcome to the
show
hi george and john how are you guys
doing today we're so great we're pumped
to be with you
what's going on i'm pumped to be with
you guys okay so my name is marquita i'm
24 years old and i'm calling um because
i'm gonna need a new car soon and by new
car i don't mean like a new car i mean
like just new to me i'm gonna need one
soon because the car that i drive now
it's 2017 honda accord with about 62 000
miles on it or so the problem is the car
belongs to my dad the titles in his name
and he paid it off last year
and he drives a 2005 chevy tahoe with
like
probably like 300 000 miles on it so
that car is on like its last legs and so
he told me he doesn't think it's going
to make it till
you know until the end of the year
really so i i really need to try to find
my own
my own wheels because yeah i i kind of
feel like i need to give this car back
to him since his car is okay you're
saying you feel like you need to has he
said hey i want the accord back
not directly no
and are you so is this is paid off you
said so you're you don't have any
financial uh interest in this car
currently right
he just kind of let you have it
yeah so this car has been with me
through college and everything so
he like was paying for it and everything
but i was like paying for you know of
course any type of maintenance or like
gas and stuff like that and like
registration inspections i was paying
for all of that kind of stuff but as far
as car payments and insurance
like he was taking care of the car my
mom was taking care of insurance so the
question is was this car a gift is it
technically your car
i feel like this was more like a loaner
car until i got settled on my feet and
could afford there's a lot there's a lot
of feelings here what is he actually
saying
i feel like i feel like what has he
actually said to you there's been a lot
of subliminal messaging as far as like
okay marissa like you got a full-time
job now so
it's like you know you probably want to
get come on now you probably you know
have you thought about getting a car
marquita that's super not subliminal
it's pretty direct
pretty direct um
how old are you again
i'm 24. so what are you doing
so i work for the state i work for the
state of north carolina okay
and
do they pay you enough to get a car
absolutely not no i have i have uh
multiple streams of income from other
forms of employment um so yeah i'm
definitely not trying to go into debt
with getting a car because i'm you know
i'm almost i'm almost done with baby
step two i got like probably like the
end of the year and then out so i'm not
trying to go in any more debt however
i've been looking around for a little
beater cars and i'm just like no take
your dad's hey take your desktop trade
them trade them straight up tell them
train them for the time i would trade
them back that's a great move and i'd
keep the tahoe and actually here's what
i would do if i'm you i would give him
350 and say dad i'd like to buy the
tahoe from you and he's going to say oh
it's a piece of junk it's whatever say i
know
uh but this the court is yours i'm going
to buy it for 350 and it's going to be
mine and then you can take it down the
courthouse and get the title and that
will buy you another year or two
okay okay and then you can give him his
car back you can stop with the this is
the
and listen from this point forward
remember this phrase clear is kind
when somebody gives you something and
you're like i don't know if say is this
a gift or is this a right be very clear
let that be a part of your language and
a part of your spirit moving forward
when you're dating somebody and they're
like it's like do you not want to go or
do you want to go like be clear right
and your life will be infinitely easier
if you do that
yeah marquita what's your income
um it's about take home was about 38 000
or so per year okay how much debt do you
have left
i have about 7 000 or so i i'm i've got
5 000 left on the student loan about 2
200 in medical but i started out way
more with student loans so i've been
paying this off since the pandemic
started when i graduated way to go
that's fantastic what do you do for the
state
i'm a cleric at a courthouse okay
you have a law degree
no i i might be pursuing that one day
but right now i gotta pay off this
undergrad debt before i can go to law
good hey you just i want you to become
an attorney because i want attorneys
like you out in the world okay with that
sense of responsibility that's fantastic
uh listen you're getting way way
underpaid
you i could tell by talking to you
you're too smart
and you uh have too much of you have too
much charisma
you bring too much to the table to make
38 thousand dollars a year i don't say
that to people who make 38 grand i'm not
saying they don't have those things i'm
saying you are worth more than you're
being paid okay yeah yeah thank you i
would get on the ball i want you making
fifty thousand dollars by the end of the
summer i'm dead serious okay
okay make it happen just get on the
phone and start calling people you're a
clerk i mean you know what i'm saying
and by the way it's a buyer's market for
law schools you'll get in if you had
good undergraduate grades you'll get
into law school you don't need to be a
clerk just to get into law school and go
get out of debt save up for law school
and then go do that
okay is that cool thank you john i
appreciate it cruise the city in this
dope 300 000 mile old tahoe that that
tahoe has been through some things okay
2005 was when i was in kindergarten okay
so i'm 24 now that's how i was hey call
it vintage that makes it cooler exactly
right that's it you just drive a vintage
car
yes and someone's gonna door ding it and
your first response is gonna be laughter
not rage right so it's you're gonna be
good to go
way to go
hey call us back when you're dead free
it lifted a huge weight off my shoulders
thank you guys wow that was worth my
friday just to do that for marquita john
and i'll tell you that is a true
statement when i drove i had an 09 honda
civic up until about a few months ago
and i love the so we had a storm come
through nashville
and a piece fell off of my house onto my
hood of my car and i was like well let's
add a little more personality
i have i have i drive an old truck and
i'll never forget i was in a parking lot
uh it was in texas it was 11 000 degrees
out it was hot and i was checking
something on my phone before i got out
and a mother pulls in with two kids in
the back and getting two kids out of out
of car seats is just a nightmare and she
got one out and that kid was just a
rascal you could tell and she was
getting the other one out and he just
kicks the door and it swings up and hits
my truck and the first thing out of the
first
response my body gave to the world was i
just died laughing yeah
oh man and i saw her she looked at that
and she we made eye contact and she and
i was like no that's why i drive this
car because i could you know i could
care less and i just have a lot less i
have no angst in my life about it right
it's just what it is that is an
underrated piece of driving a clunker is
that there's no anxiety
about taking care of making sure it
doesn't my new car already has a scrape
on it john and it gave me deep angles of
my bad sorry about that yeah no i
scraped it on my little tiny townhome
garage barely fits this boat of a car
what am i doing man what it could
i know it's not a big car i know
it's an even smaller garage no no just
blame my bad driving john why don't you
just go do that it's fine you're a bad
driver hey we got more of the show
coming up give us a call triple eight
eight two five
five two two five this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined today by best-selling
author number one best-selling author i
may add dr john deloney own your past
change your future launched earlier this
year john you're still recovering from
the book tour and the chaos yeah i mean
i thought all week it was tuesday and it
is not it is friday i'm figuring it out
the years 2022. who is the president do
i need to like test you here to make
sure you're still with us barely reagan
final answer ronald reagan here we go uh
no yeah second term george w
no it's yeah it's been a while wild ride
man yeah well the feedback's been
amazing i've i love seeing it you repost
it on your instagram people are starting
to really connect with the book and
that's pretty well it's got a new second
life to it which has been really neat
it's awesome as the friends tell their
friends you gotta read this book right
yeah that's the only way the greatest
that's the greatest uh
i mean if you
emmett smith was the greatest was one of
the greatest running backs ever but he
had the greatest offensive line ever
right so when dave ramsey's out blocking
for you
you're gonna get off the line but it's
when
a two months down the road when people
start saying hey you gotta read this and
they buy two copies for their two
friends and then that person that's when
you that ripple effect happens
that's awesome that's pretty neat well
proud of you man thanks dude all right
let's go to the phones lynn joins us up
next in jacksonville florida lynn
welcome to the ramsay show
hi thanks for having me absolutely
what's going on with you
um so i have a little bit of a situation
with one of my in-laws um
they have some pretty
poor money habits i'm actually
on baby step two myself
and so i'm having to unlearn some of my
own behaviors when it comes to money
but my in-laws kind of have this habit
of
not
budgeting their money not spending their
money wisely and then
occasionally they will have these
instances where they don't have enough
money for their necessities and they
reach out to family members asking for
their support
um and for the longest time i was
somewhat enabling this behavior
and i would give them the money and
everything like that and i tried to set
some boundaries and for a little while
it was working
but now it's kind of fallen back into
those old patterns and so my question to
you is is how can i
help them without enabling them and also
um
you know lay those boundaries and and
because it's just becoming an issue um
and i'm feeling some negative emotion
towards them because of this and being
put in this unfair position of
trying to get my debt and my
money sorted out and then also having to
take care of some adults
can i ask you a question before we get
into the the in-laws
how is is this your husband's parents
uh yes my husband's um side so how is he
in this conversation
he
is upset about it the the strange thing
is is that
the in-laws have learned to approach me
and not him oh so okay so this is this
is 95 of the time this isn't an in-law
issue it's a spouse issue but
you're the you're the problem spouse not
him
yeah that's fantastic okay so this is a
way simpler conversation way simpler um
what do what do you get out of giving
them money because you get something
what is it
um i
feel
like i'm helping them because they also
have children in the situation and so
for me it makes me feel like i'm i'm
helping
them and making sure that you know
they're taken care of so beneath that
because you know that by giving them
money
you know intellectually that you're not
helping them anymore you're enabling
yeah and so you're getting something
beneath the help what is it
honestly at this point i don't feel like
i'm getting anything out of it and
that's why i'm so upset about it but
beforehand when i was enabling this
behavior before i kind of wised up a
little bit
it was you know the validation of i'm
helping i'm feeling like a good person
things like that yes and so anytime we
go searching for external validation
it always ends up in a mess every time
and some people it takes 25 35 45 years
to figure that out you were lucky that
it happened to you early on
right yeah so i wish george you happened
here i wish i had a more complicated
answer
but really it's you and your husband
getting down uh sitting down and coming
up with
here's our boundaries this is what we
will do and this by definition is going
to define what we don't do
and then we're going to make that very
very clear and then i'm going about my
day
because my in-laws who i my personal
in-laws who i love have never asked me
for done they don't get a vote
and my parents don't either and your
in-laws do not get a vote from this
point forward and anything beyond that
is you needing to wrestle with you not
them hear what i'm saying
so lin here's if i'm in your shoes
here's what i'm doing i'm gonna have my
husband have a conversation with them
and say listen we love you guys we want
the best for you financially we want to
see you in we can no longer help you
financially but we are going to continue
to continue to help you and here's how
we're going to help we're going to help
you set up a budget we're going to help
you figure out where your money's going
we're going to help you get your income
up and cut your expenses
and they may not want that help because
it's not
it's the help they need it's not the
help they want is it
and here's what you're going to do
you're going to define what type of help
you're going to give like georgia said
we will help you we'll buy you total
money makeover in fact we'll send you a
copy that you can hand to them okay
we will um help you with a budget we'll
help you every month
but that's the help we're gonna get and
if they throw a fit and they walk away
they are choosing to not accept your
help
and chasing them around trying to come
up with the help that they will receive
which is usually cash
um is not help that is you trying to
find some external validation that by
the way you don't need you're pretty
awesome
right thank you appreciate that and we
all want our in-laws to like us all
right we all want that um that may not
be in the cards for you because it
sounds like that your in-laws are really
struggling or they're immature or
they've got addiction challenges they're
working through who knows what's going
on their life but for this season it may
not be
you had this picture in your head i'm
going to get married and my
mother-in-law are going to be close my
father law is going to be like my second
dad you that may not be the picture and
so you and your husband you said i don't
agree with that because it's not reality
you hear what i'm saying
it's it doesn't look like you thought it
was going to look and then we're just
going to make some very clear boundaries
i'm not giving them any money it's not
right i'll help coach you along but i'm
not going to keep throwing money into a
bottomless pit
lynn hang on the line we're going to
send you a copy of the total money
makeover i'm also going to give to you
one year of ramsay plus that might be
something you guys do together that
could be cool just watching all the
videos in financial peace university
that includes every dollar premium so
you can help them set up that budget i
think that's gonna be a really cool gift
and the more buy-in they see from you
guys wanting to help them maybe it could
cause them to go wow these people really
care like we should actually do this
stuff they're really you know putting
their butts in the line their time their
resources into helping us let's just do
it what's the worst that can happen
we're not gonna get more broke
and here's the deal if you
i've heard the conversation about kids
quite regularly
um
the best rescuing quote-unquote you can
do for those for somebody who's not
providing for their children somebody's
abusing their children or somebody's
neglecting their children is to call the
proper authorities in your community and
you're there you're going to be made the
bad guy and oh my gosh you're the worst
and all that kind of stuff that happens
but you just giving money to mom and dad
is not filtering down and supporting
taking care of those kids it's not
they've got to change this thing from
the inside out yeah hang online austin
will pick up we'll get you those
resources for you
all right we are back on the road john
it's been fun doing some of these events
orlando vegas have a good time man good
job it's fun just being around real
people and connecting and hearing their
stories it's inspiring to me and i'm
excited because we are heading to your
home state
texas
to dallas october 22nd it's a full day
on a saturday smart conference is back
it's been three years since we've done
this this is all your favorite speakers
on stage empowering you with tools and
principles that will create unstoppable
momentum in your life this is not
another pep talk this is thousands of
people coming together under one roof to
learn how to build wealth how to achieve
their goals strengthen relationships get
their careers in order and so much more
and you're not just gonna learn you're
gonna have a good time too smart
conference is known as one of our most
fun entertaining events all of our
ramsey personalities will be there dave
included and some special guests craig
and amy grishall from life church will
be there as well
the event passes start at just 39 i'm
telling you this is like an eight to
five event i mean just going to the
movies right now is 20 bucks my wife
just texted we were gonna surprise your
kids and i'll go tonight it's gonna be
68 bucks nope for us to go see a movie
tonight hard pass unless it's top gun or
a super hard pass so oh that's why
you're wearing a leather jacket that's
right i feel like i'm tom cruise not
gonna lie you are tom cruise 39 bucks
folks go get your passes we'd love to
see you in dallas texas do it before
they sell out because tickets are moving
people are ready to get out of the house
and go to events again go to
ramseysolutions.com
events to learn more and we will see you
in dallas texas on october 22nd more the
ramsay show coming up
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're back america this is the ramsay
show i'm george campbell joined by dr
john deloney today and in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt-free stage
jessie is with us how's it going man
good it's alright where are you from uh
outside of sioux falls south dakota
wonderful and you made the trip all the
way here to nashville tennessee to do
your debt-free screen right yep very
exciting how far is that trip
uh about 1500 miles
whoa that's a long walk man i'm glad i'm
glad that you made it
good to see you man so tell us how much
did you pay off i paid off uh 65 900
wow
how long did that take about 42 months
nice and what was your range of income
during that time from 52 000 to 61 000.
nice man what do you do for a living i
work as a cell engineer for the state of
south dakota fantastic
engineers that is the
number one millionaire career did you
know that jesse yeah and you're well on
your way now that you're debt-free man
that's awesome so what type of debt was
the 65 900
uh it was a credit card
a car and uh student loans ah you live
in that normal life man right live in la
vita broca as john likes to call it gosh
only john says you have to be in
proximity to that joke you're welcome
you're welcome so
take us back jesse 42 months ago you
decided you know what these payments
aren't so fun anymore what happened
uh it was kind of a variety of reasons
so it's kind of uh
maintaining as a when i was a teenager i
got a call from a duck collector you
know i didn't have any debt or a bank
account at the time
uh
one another one was a breakup and then
second one
uh was my grandfather was not very good
with money maybe
so that kind of gave you fuel to go not
that's not going to be me my story's
going to be different
uh tell me about this breakup what
happened uh this this is kind of a
mutual thing but it was kind of
um she was kind of teaching fpu class at
the time i was like i'm not sure if i
want to go
and so i was like i'm gonna go on a trip
to michigan and
and then so a couple of months later
kind of yeah kind of mutual world cup
and how did you get connected with our
crazy crew
uh it was kind of funny i um my cousin
had a wedding in upper michigan so like
had an 11 hour trip from there to
mitchell's uh back to
south dakota so when i got out of
minneapolis about it was late at night
so skimming through the channels and
it's like
and then came across the ramsey channels
like well i guess to listen to it for a
little bit and
they were talking about how the people
didn't have to take out student loans to
get into college i was like
well
i guess i could have done that
it was like i know there was
scholarships in my high school so i was
like well okay i'll keep listening more
and you know i'm kind of
like off slightly jealous
hindsight's 2010 you went down the
rabbit hole yeah
i think i can do this stuff yeah that's
awesome so you had a moment that was
like the earth-shattering moment like
today i'm gonna commit to being
different tell us about that day
uh i just remember going to the bathroom
and saying like i'm just sick and tired
of being the second tire and just like
the guy in the mirror and
said it's time to go it's amazing that's
hard
that's hard to do and go that guy's the
problem and that guy is a solution good
news and bad news yeah that's awesome so
what was the hardest part on this
journey getting out of debt uh i think
saying no and then also kind of maintain
a grocery budget i kind of
like to kind of eat a lot
so it's like food oh that's right gotta
eat rice and beans
oh that's awesome man so did people
think you were crazy for doing this
stuff did you have cheerleaders along
the way what was the consensus uh yes a
lot of cheerleaders a lot of challengers
you obviously yeah my fpu coordinator
nancy my parents
uh my boss jeff
uh
oh yeah tyler and amber
theresa and my co-worker thomas man you
had a whole crew supporting you that
makes all the difference having people
in your corner cheering you on when
things are hard well
take us back to the time what was the
hardest like there was a night that's
just the dark night of the soul like
what am i doing i'm missing out on this
i'm not able to do that i'm so if i eat
another bean
literally i'm going to spontaneously
come no more legumes no more look at him
take us back to that moment and you and
you powered through
um i think the hardest one in april 2020
uh i wasn't got it uh in a car crash
uh the guy came 30 miles an hour hit my
car
uh t-bone kind of spun the car so i was
kind of
kind of mind-boggled a little bit it's
like okay like
i'll see what the claims and do and kind
of kind of work it out and
uh but yeah eventually the insurance
came back around
they said like they valued the car at 13
000
uh
then the current loan i had at the time
was ten thousand
so when they paid it off it's like
well is this kind of usual you have we
have money left over for you they will
send you a check yeah wow and you're
doing okay everything's good health
it's good
yep all i got was the bruise right here
so kind of a nice yellow spot kind of
went away yeah yeah well that's
definitely a bump in the journey to say
the least
so how does it feel to be completely
debt-free paying off almost 66 grand in
42 months oh it's it's great i ain't
just i feel like i have options for the
future and i don't have to go like
okay i gotta say
save money for my past mistake for my
past me but now i can save
money for future me amen yeah man well
we're so proud of you so what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is
um i think
i remember the first quote i comes to
mind
was uh it was quite a while back when i
started it was that
discipline is the bridge between goals
and accomplishments oh that's good i
think a lot of self-discipline
just pressure variants and just kind of
working out details and yeah man it
changed so much more than your money it
changes you right and that's huge and
now now there's nothing you can't tackle
now that you've built that discipline in
one area you go i could do that over
here and over here and over here in my
career and my physical health and it's
inspiring we're proud of you man
you ready to do this thing yeah okay
well we got a copy of dave's number one
best-selling book baby steps
millionaires that is absolutely the next
chapter in your story we're also going
to give you a copy of the total money
makeover to inspire someone else's
debt-free journey along the way
and on top of that we're going to give
you a gift a gift card for one year of
ramsay plus which includes all the
videos in financial peace university
every dollar premium our budgeting tools
so you can hand this to someone or
experience it for yourself and keep you
motivated along the journey
all right thanks awesome man all right
let's get to it it's jesse from sioux
falls south dakota 65 900 paid off in 42
months making 52 all the way up to 61
000
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream oh no dos trace oh i'm dead
yes
1 000 yes
[Applause]
amazing dude he broke the metal core on
that one i loved it that was visceral
yes i felt that in my triceps
you don't have triceps okay but yeah you
felt that i know that was incredible wow
way to go jesse so proud of you man good
stuff is it bad that i'm kind of biased
towards
of rip roar and sometimes people go
through a debt free screen they're all
everyone's great everyone's got their
story and every personality is different
sometimes they have this great story
like i did it i persevered i came
through
i'm debt free
and i always think 100
low-key i'm pretty sure the booth the
booth rates the debt-free screams behind
the scenes for fun yeah oh man they're
drinking the haterade back there that
was a 10 out of 10. that's a judge
they're all holding up the cards they
say 10 out of 10. that's amazing jessie
shows up here and brings the thunder all
this intense
from south dakota he's got some pipes
yeah he does he's definitely in a
medical metalcore band on the side
that's exactly right and you've been to
a lot of those shows john so you know
shoes that's amazing when you
just just as a reminder i know you've
talked about this a lot george
tell the audience what it feels like
when you oh nobody anything
uh it feels like you're just on a cloud
you just feel lighter like physically
lighter when you say that
i'm like all right that sounds like
you're okay that's cute like
you literally walk a light there's a new
level of confidence when i walk around i
wear leather jackets now john yeah
because i don't have them which makes me
want to hang on to my mortgage a little
bit longer you'll get there i'll get
there you'll get there that's fair but
really you just kind of walk around and
every paycheck that comes in you get to
decide what happens to every dollar so
you're in control you have options
you've got freedom you have margin
and you make decisions differently based
on all of those things so we see an
opportunity where we can bless someone
we go let's do it it's not a
conversation we don't have to save uh
you just go yeah absolutely let's go out
to eat it changes everything so if
you're not dead free highly recommend it
and you can do it jesse did it and we're
rooting for all
yes thank you so much more of the ramsay
show coming up
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
dolone and we are taking your calls and
we are pumped to take them aren't we
john
that's right we are pumped
triple eight eight two five five two two
[ __ ] like an 80s or nothing like that
basketball team
sure
that's what people think when they see
us john no they don't think that but
they do when they hear us say i'm so
pumped
do you use that word in like a regular
language yeah that's hip like your
wife's like hey let's go out tonight
you're like i'm pumped no i don't use
that term with my wife it's with the
bros you know me and james were hanging
out on the weekends
and he's like hey you wanna um play our
offenders and listen to this the joke
was james has never hung out with me i
know he doesn't do that but it's fine uh
i'm gonna play some fenders and listen
to some sad songs and you're like i'm
pumped that's how that goes yep
well
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com well that was that was a that
was like that transition subtle turn
there you like that somebody's a radio
pro their 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure which john is prone to do or
you pick the wrong color which i am
prone to do they will remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
and you know i love a good deal so use
the promo code ramsay to get the best
deal
all right today's question comes from
katie in texas katie writes
my spouse and i are newlyweds and debt
free
he works in construction however he
finds every excuse he can not to work
at the beginning of the pandemic new
construction was briefly suspended but
when he was given the chance to return
the choice to return he chose not to and
remained off the job for more than three
months
we both had coveted last year and he
stayed off work for two months because
he had lingering fatigue he recently got
sick again with a seasonal cold but he
still hasn't returned to work he says he
chose his career so he can stockpile
money and stop working when he feels
like it but his lack of vision disturbs
me
the money he stockpiles will run out and
he's not saving for our future he's
saving for his leisure time
how do i start a discussion with him
about his lack of motivation to work
okay a couple things here number one
katie you're conflating a lot and i'm
reading between the lines here but you
don't believe that he's actually sick
and you don't believe that he's actually
tired
um you believe that he's lazy that's how
you wrote this um
if he's got long code if he's still
struggling with stuff he needs to go to
a doctor and begin the process of
getting
healed to be getting well right
and for some folks it's a mess of a
journey for others it's a matter of
changing some things and getting the
right medications that they need to go
get well so that's number one so let's
move this over and let's assume
he doesn't have um
relative tragic uh long covet here which
i've heard about okay let's move that
over
let's suggest that you got a husband
that's just lazy he doesn't want to work
he's got some scam figured out where he
can work two days out of a month and
make enough money to slide by and keep
his halo subscription going
this is a hard george a hard
conversation to have and it does not
start with you're lazy or you never work
it starts with i'm scared
i'm scared about my future i'm scared
about our future i'm scared about what's
next for us and your lack of
um leadership your lack of getting on
the same page with me
leave feels makes me feel completely
exposed i'm not sleeping i'm not able to
to go about having joy in my life
because you are not a part of what we're
doing here and that is a radically
different conversation fewer people
respond viscera bit more viscerally to
that conversation they are out there
idiots like i'm just being me bro that's
a whole other
that's a left turn here but
most people when you come at them with
you need to sell the truck or you need
to fix this you got to get off your butt
they go into fight or flight they shut
down the conversation's over when you
sit down and make it about you i'm
scared i'm not okay because you're not
you're not in this with me yeah that's a
different path forward well and these
are newlyweds i go man this should be
like an exciting time yeah you're having
fun and this doesn't sound fun it
doesn't sound like there's a lot of
excitement unless he feels like i got my
i got my meal ticket right i married a
steady paycheck and now i can just sit
at home yeah i mean they're debt-free
which is good but i still can't imagine
that you can just not work for a few
months and be okay financially so now
this was a line that got me john he says
he chose this career so he can stockpile
money
i don't stop working for that reason
it's a terrible reason to choose so i'm
going he needs to find work he actually
enjoys because it's clearly not
construction right yeah he doesn't like
construction he doesn't he chose it
because he thought it's easy money which
if you've been in construction it's not
it's not easy money but you can work on
a job site for four days out of out and
get paid and take a few days that week
take a few weeks off which is a terrible
way to do life because there's going to
come a moment when that four day work
day doesn't exist a four-day work week
doesn't exist and you're then you're
broke right yeah um but yeah he doesn't
this guy hasn't shown up for his life
you know what i mean he's got no
interest in his life yeah beyond the not
going to work he's not engaged in life
yeah he's in this marriage he's a child
yeah to your point it she needs to go
hey i don't feel good about this i feel
unsafe i want you to be excited about
our future yes and that means caring
about goals caring about how we're going
to get there caring about yourself yes
right looking in the mirror and saying
i'm worth a life better than
a couple of days silly and bricks
at a site and then staying home for the
next two weeks right yeah that's a
totally different thing and if you're
sick if you actually are not okay
sometimes guys like to flex and be like
nah it's cool bruh i supposed to sit at
home if you're not okay go to the doctor
you know what i mean go get the help you
need go see a counselor get the help
that you need to show up for yourself
and for your wife man life's too short
dude life's too short agreed thanks for
the question thanks katie terry joins us
up next in austin terry welcome to the
show
hey how's it going guys thanks for
having me great how can we help
um
tell me how to get myself out of this
giant hole that i've dug
um describe the hole
well um i've been looking over the
numbers and i'm showing i'm right at
thirty seven thousand five hundred
dollars in credit card debt um
if i add my s well credit cards my car
and then if i add student loans that
adds about forty five thousand to it it
adds 45 so what's the total amount of
debt
yes uh student loans and credit cards as
right under 80 000 like 77 000 okay
what's your income
uh right now it's about 45 000 40 to 45
000 a year okay
what's the car worth
um i just got the car a couple months
ago um
so honestly i could probably sell it for
maybe
three grand less than i paid for it how
much would that be
um i show right at 20 uh right at thirty
thousand dollars
sell it sell it immediately today this
weekend gone um
well the issue i have no issues
no issues just sell it just sell it just
sell it it's my source of income though
your car is your source of income
yes describe that
um so
i was working doordash full-time um
making about fifteen hundred dollars a
week okay um and then the car that i had
which was paid off
in my name it i blew a hole in the block
and i went a month without being able to
get work or do anything because i lived
in the
20 miles from town
um so i went out and got this car
because it's easier to walk into a
dealership and get a car with no money
than it is to walk into you know a shop
and get your car fixed with no money
and my plan was to get rid of like after
i get my debt squared away fix my old
car and didn't get rid of this car
terry here's the deal man i'm trying to
make the money there's there's no reason
you had to go out and get a 30 000 car
making 40 grand all in the name of i do
doordash
what are you doing brother
so we can help you get out of debt all
day but we gotta get to the root i know
you're trying to get by man
you're just digging the hole making it
deeper and deeper and deeper i know it
feels like you got to be running because
you're scared and i get that man but you
got to stop okay stop
so
terry what was the credit card dead in
you had 37 000 what was what were the
purchases
um
it's just
usually paying bills and stuff to get by
um
like i said 30 grand of that is the car
um if i exclude the car it's
closer to five grand okay
well selling the car is going to clean
this up you need to find a way to
produce more income it may not be
doordash maybe a career change to start
making 50 60 70 even if it's for a short
time yeah get after it but this is going
to take some intense sacrifice it's
going to have to take a mindset shift
where you go
debt is not an option anymore
no more 30 000 get a 5 000 car man and i
want you to feel the sacrifice and it's
not going to feel good but when you're
debt free you will say this was a
hundred percent worth it and we can get
a nicer car later when we have the money
for it thanks for the call man this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600-plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell your host joined today
by dr john deloney some call it the
dream team
no one calls it that john i'm sorry
i tried you and i call it that we high
five each other and chest bump in the
hallway it's like this is the dream team
we are pumped to take your call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number to call and chris is
kicking off this hour in columbus ohio
chris welcome to the show
thank you i appreciate it guys i
appreciate you taking my call i would
wish you a happy uh national donut day
but of course i'm dark and i didn't get
to do that ah well i didn't know it was
happening national donut day gosh what a
terrible time i chose to cut out my
calendar yeah what's up man
so um i am uh
we started uh the ramsey plan a couple
years ago and of course me and being one
of those guys uh i know they talked
about i didn't follow it completely
yes and then uh you know i was paying
off her credit card every month you know
not accumulating
uh not getting interest and then you
know i wasn't so
you know i i decided it was time to
not lock the line let's just get stuck
um so you're ready to go all in is that
what you're committing to on this call
yeah love it yeah well for sure yeah
okay we're all in
um
so what i'm dealing with though is i am
um i'm uh we're a one income family
and we have a pretty large family
actually and we're uh uh we're gonna be
a family setup we have a new one uh
that's gonna be coming next month so
exciting time but you know it's a hard
time to start in this process and uh you
know trying to get out of that um so i
i'm really you know just trying to
figure out a way
when you know i
both me and my my wife doesn't work a
job but she works at home plenty so
probably get extra income and
also um you know i feel like it's
probably not a wise decision that's been
money to get out of that you know like i
i heard
um a show not too long ago where you
know we talked about you know it's a
good time to you know fix cars and i can
i actually work on my car to fix them
and you know try to sell it for more but
that
has an investment in the beginning or
even like we were looking at the ramsey
plus right which i think would help us
but you know is it just a good time to
spend money to like actually get an
income let's not go that route as our
first option for sure yeah so what's
your income now
uh about 63 to 65. okay what do you do
i am a business analyst at a i think
cool okay and you're looking to increase
your income clearly your wife's got
plenty on her blight and so you are
going to be
you're going to be our ticket here to
get rid of this debt faster how much
debt do you have
uh we are sitting right about just about
11 000. 11 thousand okay what kind of
debt yeah
uh
about two thousand twenty five hundred
on the credit card and then the rest is
uh a car payment a car payment what's
the car worth
uh it's right around that amount okay
uh what's the amount
uh it's about 8 500 so i'm going to
guess around 8 to 10.
okay
cool what kind of car is this
i hit the van to carry everybody in i
figured it was a kid hauler
okay well to me making 65k what's the
current rate of debt payoff for 11 000
according to your estimations
um so i i'm really
i
i think it's going to take us a couple
years if we just make minimum payments
which i don't want to do well sorry so
how are you going george
63 000 with seven kids you have no
margin you all barely make it every
month is that right
exactly yeah i mean you can't breathe
fair
so yeah we we've already cut out you
know like we don't do cable
you know i did cancel like our two
streaming services
but we got that out of the way i'm all
about cancelling screens but you got
seven kids even you deserve a streaming
service okay um
here's the thing
like
this is just two guys hanging out having
chips in queso okay
uh
like
i can hear it the frenetic-ness in your
voice your life is chaos is that fair
uh it hasn't left them now
it's quieter at night it's not spoken
like a true business analyst at a bank
right it's you know the market goes up
it goes down listen
what i want for you what george and i
want for you is that you be able to
breathe
and with your set of skills i want you
to go find a job that's doubling your
income
and that might mean you have to leave a
bank that you really love the people but
you've created a life for yourself that
involves seven mouths to feed
and so there's nine of you and i don't
know that you'll make it on 63 000
i want you to go find a job or two jobs
for a season
and let your wife know we're gonna make
some sacrifices that are gonna be gnarly
for 24 months
so that
we can all breathe and the kids are
going to get their dad back and you're
going to get your husband back because
right now even when you're home you're
still rattling is that fair
oh yeah for sure i i my goal was to
find it sell everything you know i've
heard that's all everything about the
kids but i don't know you know if you
can have kids work you know we've got
plenty of that
no you can't you can't
the best solution is uh chris goes and
finds a better business analyst job i
just did a quick google search in ohio
the average salary for a business
analyst in ohio 79 000
and so to me you're saying you make 63 i
think it's time to go job searching and
clean up the resume ken coleman's got
some great resources for nailing the
interview cleaning up the resume and
getting that job we'll send you a copy
of paycheck to purpose so you can get
your kickstarter on that journey okay
for sure
but that's gonna be your best way to
increase income quickly without working
80 hours a week and never seeing your
five kids
seven kids yeah well you got a family of
seven right five
uh i thought
i thought you said it changes everything
okay john says no excuses
that's easy yeah right
i have two kids i don't even know what
day it is man um here here's the thing i
i i
something's gonna have to give
and i don't want it to be you and your
sanity and i don't want it to be your
marriage and i don't want to be your
kids
so the only thing left in that equation
is either geographic area which
if you're plugged in you're plugged in
or it's going to have to be a new job or
two new jobs and that might mean you
have to get some new training get
retooled at some things or it might mean
like george said i just got to spend
some evenings over the next couple of
months sending out resumes like crazy
calling some old contacts connecting
with people that i know in other banks
and other industries maybe go work for
the state whatever that looks like
and i want you to sit down and make a
goal i want to make 120 000
that's my goal
and you've got a job now that you've got
so when you are negotiating when you're
sitting down with what do you need i
need about 120 right you can start to
put these numbers out there without
having to worry about food because you
already have a job but i i think you're
worth that and this will give you some
space there's no business taking two
years to pay off 11 000 bucks that
should be four or five months and i want
you to set yourself up financially so
you can do that yeah to create that
margin and what you're going to need for
the rest of the baby steps getting the
emergency fund in place investing paying
off the house so this is going to be a
long-term solution which i like for you
thanks for the call chris this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
delony
so john we get a lot of emails that
flood this place um you know some some
good some bad some people just want to
warn others of what's going on in their
world and so we got some emails that i
want to share with you today that i
think might grind your gears
one is from kendrick and here's what
kendrick had to say
the bank in my town encouraged parents
to bring their children in to get a
micro loan to start a lemonade stand
what are your thoughts on this event
pictures attached let's see those
pictures
look at this okay it says we have 30
dollar micro loans for your lemonade
stand business youth entrepreneurs offer
offer good to the first 50 applicants
of registered lemonade day businesses
wow okay and there's a said photo of a
child who's very excited meeting a
frightening frightening man who has a
lemon
head
mask thing what is going on here john
i
and here's what they're saying some of
these kiddos are having so much fun with
lemonade day makes lemmy so happy
they're not gonna have fun when they're
figuring out how many preparations works
from their hemorrhoids wow because gosh
hey can we all just say this
camilla says as a society can we leave
the kids alone
what about your life when you look at it
and you owe banks everything they own
your house they own your cars they own
your couches that you think you know
what the best thing i could do is wrote
my kid into this
god almighty stop and banks
dude that's my best friends on the
planet working banks i have high respect
but don't go after children they don't
need 30 dollars to have a lemonade stand
you know what you could do is you could
have a how to let them go pull weeds
around your building day stop hiring
some fancy crew hire some kids to do it
so they can earn 10 bucks and they can
go cash flow their lemonade stand and
then they can deposit their money in
their bank so you can use it for
whatever you can loan it out to some
other more but leave the kids
alone dude george this is a lemonade and
drink it normally i have fun this pisses
me off this is yeah i mean it's funny
that kid is excited you know why because
somebody handed him cash and he has no
idea what he just signed up for
thirty dollar loan how about just i
don't know go to your local walmart and
get some lemonade packets and make it
for a dollar well it might be thirty
dollars now inflation george what is the
startup cost for lemonade business that
orange face
or the big yellow lemon face is gonna
give the kids john there's more where
that came from you want more of this
keep them coming okay emily emailed in
this is on a related note she said i bet
your team is already aware of this but i
was shocked to see a credit card company
trying to get my 14 year old hooked on
student loans i don't even know how they
got his name or address this is from
discover student loans
and
it talks about get a student loan that
works for you yeah all caps will cover
up to 100 of school certified costs with
zero fees we reward you for good grades
that's right if you have a 3.0 or higher
you can get a one-time cash flow
discover of one percent of the loan
amount
wow a 14 year old john
14.
i just went from hemorrhoids to just
plain old rocket diarrhea without wow
that one's listen it got dark real quick
no cause
oh gosh
no
john can't even talk he's so happy he
gets so angry
because they're here's what they're
doing to children
they are weaponizing
the brain chemistry that is connected to
relationships
and you've got these companies going
after children saying i'm on your team
you can do life better with me
and so
uh
sign up young and i'm gonna reward you
and to a small to a youngster's brain to
a child's brain
they go sweet and for many kids they're
getting rewards nowhere else and the
idea that somebody reached out and said
hey i see you and i'm going to reward
you that kid goes i'm in i'm in and now
they're hooked for life because they are
oh golly dude john you worked in higher
ed for many years and you've seen how
predatory these companies are towards
college students but now that they're
going after teenagers and young children
even younger than that and normalizing
debt to go oh i took out a 30 lemonade
loan when i was a kid at least when i
was 20 and 19
i was an adult right and not a not a
very smart one
not 14
not 10 not 11 not six let's all agree
to leave the kids alone and by the way
mom and dad i don't know where they got
this stuff they get that crap off of
social media they get that stuff off of
your kids signing up for things with
this address it's not just magic right
or you're putting your kids names down
so be super protective of where your
your kids are putting their addresses
and their names because these aggregate
companies are selling this stuff to
people like that who show up and knock
on the door as the friend fairy and
saying hey
i love you and i'll give you money and
i'll reward you gosh it gets me so
enraged so parents they're not innocent
in this john because there's a lot of
parents out there who go well it's good
for junior to learn how credit works no
he needs to understand he needs to learn
he needs to understand how to pay back
his debt in a wise way so here's how
this isn't a theory this isn't me just
being upset
this is my house
i had 12 year old
and he is too young to go get a formal
job at a at a bank right or at
mcdonald's or whatever
um
he is old enough to go next door across
the street and help our neighbors out in
the country with their horses and
literally shoveling cha-cha with a huge
shovel and learning how the polaris
works and how to spread manure out on a
field to help the grass like he's
learning so many cool skills right and
he's earning a little bit of money that
then he can put aside and say hey i want
to invest in this or i want to start he
wants to start selling some of our
chickens eggs and so it's like cool you
can't afford to even do that yet to buy
the entry fee to the to the ag to the
um whatever you call them uh the the
saturday when they get together the
farmer's market so let's go earn some
money so that you right yes so we're
going to say we'll teach them how to
work not teach them how to borrow how to
cut the system how to hack the system
man we got to teach our kids that money
comes from work not from lenders who are
not your friends not your friends and
all the marketing they want you to go
john we care about you we want to give
you some money to help you gosh hey pull
that pull that ad back up i want to f i
want i want to know this cause this is
going to tell me whether
these are good people the lemonade one
yes it's up there are these good people
who have trying to trying to teach kids
how banks work which is not what i want
to teach my my 12 year old but i get the
sentiment
here's how i know
do they charge interest on this loan
i don't see anything about interest
there's no telling because if they don't
charge interest if they give a kid a 30
micro loan for their lemonade business
the kids got to return the 30 after
after two weeks
then they're teaching the kid that
money's free
and just like a drug dealer when the
first yeah man just take these joints
these are free and then we come back
later then this kid's gonna learn the
hard way when he takes out a car loan or
a student loan oh no no no we take a big
chunk of that back you owe us interest
on that thing if they're charging these
kids interest then at least they're
teaching them the whole i mean they're
showing them the full 2035. 35
at least you're being honest um but if
you just give the kid the money and then
have them bring it back to you dude you
are just giving him that first drug that
first hit that's john a lot of people go
well it's okay i do credit cards i pay
them off every month and the problem
with all of this is you normalize the
behavior and you go it's okay to use
someone else's money to live my life
and all of a sudden you go from 14 to 16
to 18 and you go well i grew up watching
my parents with payments so it's no it's
good
going to the bank and they all cheered
me when they gave me thirty dollars
right to go start my business and then
you go to college and this discover is
there at a table with a free t-shirt and
a pizza if you sign up for their credit
card and they're gonna send you uh notes
and five dollars for a's
[Music]
i don't know dude let's just say this as
a society let's leave the kids alone you
can get outside and make your grown-up
decisions let's leave the kids alone man
that's just it just
i got two little kids it just hits me in
the guts i hate it man john i warned you
this was going to grind your gears and i
think my gears are sufficiently ground
here we go we got there didn't know i
had gears to grind but they're ground so
parents remember more is caught than
todd if you want to help your kids avoid
the mistakes that maybe you've
experienced or you've watched your
parents experience you can change your
family tree but it starts with teaching
them that debt is not a tool to be
leveraged and look at your life if
you're if you're swallowed up in debt
commit to not at least not passing that
on to your kids let your kid watch you
become debt free and watch how that
changes your family tree
that is what i want to teach my kids not
how to get thirty dollars to start a
lemonade stand that's so ridiculous i
don't want your lemonade go do something
more i do want your lemonade i just
wanna pick cash for it there we go i
still don't want the lemonade john too
much sugar trying to watch my physique
anyways this is the rainbow jacket of
yours we'll be back soon
[Music]
[Music]
all right so a lot of people would
rather spend their weekend doing yard
work than talk about insurance
except for me john i like your workout
and i like insurance more than yard work
but here's the deal if you don't take
the time to learn about this stuff
you'll always feel like you're getting
ripped off or making all the wrong
choices about your insurance and around
here we think learning about money
should be simple and yes even fun and so
our new free five-day guide to insurance
called confidence in your coverage makes
learning about insurance quick and
practical and you might even laugh out
lied out out loud a time or two and
here's why i know that because i filmed
the videos john it was me i got to do
you read better than you just did
hopefully there was a prompter all right
so that was very helpful very good so
for five days every single day i will
walk you through a new insurance topic
in three minutes or less unpacking
everything you need to know to get the
right coverage for you to top it off
we're doing a giveaway for the folks who
sign up for this series so at the end of
the series you'll still have yard work
it'll be there but at least you'll know
your stuff when it comes to insurance so
go to ramseysolutions.com
confidence to sign up and get started
again that's ramseysolutions.com
if nothing else sign up so that i can
feel good because i worked hard on these
videos right now there's some people
saying hey i think i want to go see the
new top gun this weekend and somebody
just went
hold on insurance video series five
insurance videos we can watch but if
you're gonna have to learn about it let
it be from me in three minutes or less
for five days
i agree with that
i agree with that that's what i want
it's better than scrolling instagram and
finding your tick tock video that's 32
seconds of some that's true unless it's
me teaching you about insurance on a
tick tock video please don't do that
okay be better
be better than that well sign up ramsay
solutions.com confidence i know john's
gonna do it he needs all the confidence
i'm about to walk off the set and go uh
watch those videos thank you it's gonna
be hard for me to grind out the last 20
minutes here let's go to the phones
because that's what i do when i want
john to stop talking britney joins us up
next she's in baltimore brittany welcome
to the show
thank you how's it going
yes you sound great
thanks for taking my call um i want to
thank the dave ramsey team for helping
us get debt free a number of years ago
awesome
but my question is more appointing to
help with
helping someone my spouse who has been
retired due to a disability for about 10
years
um we are in a situation right now where
we're cash flowing the kids college we
are building a new home and with the
current market those prices have come in
about 20 higher uh than we've expected
and i'm encouraging him to go back to
work but he's full of false starts and
this has been going on for 10 years
and i really you know i've tried the
soft approach i've tried the
ambivalent approach i've i i
can't get into church i don't know what
else to do and i'm running out of
options and i'm running out of time
when you say you're running out of time
what does that mean
well
i'm at the age where i have about 10
years left in my career
and we're taking on a much larger
mortgage than we had originally
predicted and so that either means that
we take that on and we sell the house
once we will no longer lose money
um
or i'm gonna have to work much longer
than i had planned
but we both have
um we both have our limitations yeah
um he has a number of illnesses as a
result of being a first responder
he has a couple of layers of ptsd
um and i've got some neurological damage
from
from some long-term illness okay
so
what i hear in the house here's what i
hear in your house
that you have a
you've done this for a decade you're
tired and you decide i'm gonna go on
living my life
and that life is going to include a
house that you finally been wanting for
so long the house is it's going to
include this it's going to include that
you're about to set yourself up for a
disaster
okay
on a couple of fronts front number one
you've got to look at the last decade as
a
strong data set that suggests what the
next decade is going to look like
financially for you
and so taking on a giant mortgage with
somebody who's struggling with a number
of challenges is not wise i get that you
need it that you want it that you can't
wait for it but i'm just telling you
someone who cares about you it's not
wise
the second thing is is you've reached
the point where i'm just gonna start
lobbing grenades
it's not gonna be the
you're not gonna get the resolution that
you want
it's not a someone hasn't yelled at him
in the right way to get him up
and i know that's hard to hear the
hardest thing to hear is you can't make
him be motivated
and you're feeling though as though he
is not doing this to spite you because
he doesn't care about your dreams and
he's not doing this because he feels
like he's broken
and he's hurt and he's made some choices
to not get well i'm not he needs to get
up and go get well
and he's choosing not to right
but but i out of your anger and
frustration and i i know it's real so
hear my voice i'm not discounting you've
been doing this for a decade and you
love this man a lot right but god
almighty go get a job right i get that
but don't let that fire you off into a
mortgage that you simply can't handle
and to having to work to be 80 years old
to pay for a house that you really
probably should never bought in the
first place
the ultimate question here and this is a
scary question is the or what
and so i'll ask you publicly and you can
say i'm not ready to answer that that's
fine
are you gonna leave him
are you there don't think i've i don't
think i've gotten to that point yet okay
but i've got to do something because
this is taking an emotional
toll on me and it's starting to drag on
my resilience on my health that's yes
have you had the car i know you've had
every conversation in the book have you
sat down with him and said i'm scared
about what's next for us yes okay what
does he say to that
i get a false start he bought your book
and he said
well i've already done the career i
wanted to do
i
i don't know
again another false start yeah
um have you gone to talk to somebody
i have okay was he willing to join you
no
so this is gonna be hard for me to say
out loud but this is where we're at
you get to choose
this is the guy i'm with
this is the person that i'm i'm married
this is who they have become i don't
love it for them i don't love it for us
but this is it
i'm not going to leave them i'm here
and so i'm going to look at the
financial realities the marital
realities the relational realities of
that world
or
you can say i'm going to start making
plans to do something different
and all of the downstream challenges
that that's going to involve
but choosing to let this situation
slowly steal your joy and your heart and
what resilience you've got left and your
exhaustion and bringing the just walking
around inflamed all the time
i'll just tell you to love yourself
enough to not do that make peace with
where you are and choose to say okay
i've gotta make i've gotta create live a
world of joy inside this mess or
i've got to make some pretty radical
changes but right now you're just in
limbo you hear what i'm saying
i do
i do that and i what i'm saying is
tear-inducing it's terrifying it's scary
you got a house that you've been working
i mean the whole thing right i get that
but you're drowning slowly
yes right
i need you to hear me say you're worth
more that he is too man i would do
anything for him to get up and get well
i would love that
but a cornerstone the second step of
getting well is looking in the mirror
and owning reality okay this is the way
this is has he told you he's just never
going to do anything he just won't i
mean what's what's the
is there just no momentum is he just is
he just really suffering from depression
just and just kind of locked in place
there
yeah does he have some guys that could
come over and talk to him some old guys
from his old units to come over
nope have you thought to reach out to
some of them
he will not
he might not but you're welcome to
invite people to your house
i've tried that
nothing
nothing okay
britney is it too late to back out of
this house situation even even if you
lose a deposit no
now it's uh too far in but it's you know
it's a situation that it'll be
marketable and so you know i don't have
to endure it terribly well
well you're so excited about this house
and this the day one you're already
gonna be stressed about it wanting to
get rid of it
i know so i would look into all your
options on that side and maybe cash flow
in college you go hey kids we're going
through a lot right now financially
college is on you because we don't want
to be a burden to you guys when you're
out of college because we can't retire
that's right or in a semester we're
gonna we're gonna have to take a break
um
if you're
a guy and you're in the situation you're
listening to this
please for your sake for your family say
go get well go call somebody and say
today's gonna be the day
and i hate this is your situation i wish
we could have a rosy ending to this call
but there's a hard reality to your
situation
and you're gonna have to decide to make
peace
or to make some transitions and i'm not
gonna make that for you you gotta make
that call
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
psalm 119
89-90
your word lord is eternal it stands firm
in the heavens your faithfulness
continues through all generations you
establish the earth and it endures
charles spurgeon said by perseverance
the snail reached the arc
good stuff
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five i'm george
campbell joined by dr john dolone john's
on the line in new york city john
welcome to the show
hi ken and john thank you so much for
taking my call and really appreciate all
the work that you guys do happy to do it
what's going on
yeah so um i've lived in new york city
my whole life born and raised here and
i'm looking to purchase a one-bedroom
apartment here which
um you know the price point that i'm
looking at and seeing for something
that's not a total closet is
around 600 to 750 000
and you know over the past years i've
worked really hard and followed your
guidance and teachings to get to the
point where i have the ability to put
down 20 percent
and
when i look at my budget the past few
years i think from an income perspective
it actually makes sense to uh
to do that but i figure if i do it on a
15-year fix and do 20
down i'm looking at approximately
37
of my take-home pay
and then if i do
um
i into a 30-year it would be 29
now the take-home pay after taxes is
approximately 12 and a half thousand
dollars per month
so
um if i went with the highest higher end
of that 750 k 15-year fixed looking at
about 4 700. now my intuition is as a
25-year-old single person the 8 000
per month after the um
after the housing payment
i mean when i look at my budget the past
few years i'm spending you know at most
1500 1750 on the really really high end
per month on expenses outside of housing
so i figured that
you know i should be okay i mean that
school would leave about six six
thousand and sixty five hundred left
over in
um an income for me to use for investing
retiring and uh you know ultimately
powering me through baby steps four and
hopefully six even paying that number
down early but you know your teachings
and guidance have always been really
valuable so i was just wondering if you
know
if maybe my case might be an exception
to the 25
um
25 percent of take-home payroll that you
guys have uh
had over the past few years
well john we get these calls you know
fairly often where people go am i the
exception to the rule and in this case
you're not special and you might i mean
you're a special guy you're a one of a
kind guy but you don't get a pass on
math because you live in new york city
now what's your income
you said you have 12 you take home
last year um i was at about 210 000 and
then this year i'm pacing for about
260. you're amazing at 25 years old
what's your what's your line of work
uh i tell technology for a living and
i've just followed the principles that
you know dave and you guys have taught
just keeping my head down working the
whole day and putting in those 55 plus
hour weeks and
i mean yeah i mean i'm very blessed and
fortunate to be in a position where i
can have a good income at this point
that's awesome and your after tax income
before you know take out 401ks and
health insurance what is that number per
month oh um after just testing out
i did take out 401k and health insurance
to get to that 12 and a half k number
without it
um
probably i'd say about 14k after taxes
no health insurance and no 401k perfect
new york city has the extra four and a
half percent
uh tasks that they kind of and the
bonuses the bonus yeah hey uh i'm
hopping here george is walking you
through this um are you are you
commission based
um i'm 50 50. a good amount of this
commission okay all right so
based on my math here i'm using the
mortgage calculator on our website you
would need a down payment of about 200
grand a little more maybe to get into
this place and not have it be
you know cause you to be house poor so
how much money do you have right now
saved up for the down payment
yeah um so for the down payment i've got
150k delineated for that and then i've
got an emergency fund of 30 and then i
have another
40 that's currently um in mutual funds
in a brokerage outside of retirement
sweet i could go to 190
without and still keep the emergency
fund so this feels great then because
now i'm going all right how fast can we
save up another 10 grand probably
a month or two two months yeah and so
this is where i start to feel good about
it because now we're not trying to skirt
it we're not trying to find shortcuts
we're just looking at the math of it to
go oh you can still live your life with
an amazing income and you said it's only
going up which means we can pay this
thing off faster and so i would not do a
30-year i would not put less down i'm
just going to keep saving and with your
income this is not a huge problem and
how old are you man
i'm 25 25 okay so you've been
um since you've been working
you've you
i mean as you entered into this field
and you've been crushing it you've been
at the back end of one of the law or the
longest bull run in the history of
humanity okay the largest wealth
accumulation
that has happened in a single run you
that's that's been the only years you've
worked
what you haven't been and
unfortunately all of us who are old have
is the seasons of crushing it
followed by nobody's buying any tech for
three years because their businesses are
trying to hang on right and so what
here's the math isn't to punish you
it's to prepare you not if but when
a season comes that suddenly your your
your income drops to 150 or it drops to
95 which is a great salary
but it cannot float the scheme that you
cooked up you hear what i'm saying and i
know in your head
you're like dude that's never going to
happen i've made 210 and this year
making 260. next year i'm projected to
make
just trust me haven't been on the roller
coaster enough that sucker eventually
has to come down right
and it's just preparing yourself if it
comes down i got i'm 20 of my
i've got to be able to
cover 25
of my take-home pay that's a lot of loss
you can stomach in your salary in your
commissions and still not lose your home
you see what i'm saying
yeah absolutely that that makes a lot of
sense and you know that's kind of why i
want to continue to save and invest you
know even if
so with the 25 you know hopefully i can
still
save you know maybe i only spend another
25 on top of that still save half my
income so i can have that
that nice uh you know hefty amount in
mutual funds so
you know should i need to go beyond my
emergency fund or should um should
anything happen i can still back that up
and still sustain the mortgage and not
have to go into any sort of distress
yeah it gives you options and
a lot of freedom there and that's what i
love about a 15-year fixed-rate mortgage
where the payment's no more than a
quarter of your take-home pay is that
you still have 75 of your take-home pay
to accomplish all of your other goals to
invest and save up your kids college or
buy the engagement ring or pay the house
pay for the pay the house off the
apartment off and on top of that guess
what 15-year fixed-rate mortgage pays
off in 15 years every single time and
that's a worst case scenario which means
at 40 years old if you just made minimum
payments just those same mortgage
payments you would have a paid for
property in new york city at 40 years
old that probably has appreciated up to
a million dollars or if you're a single
25 year old and you work like bananas
like he's been doing because he's this
guy's brilliant
he's a hustler
and you have this thing paid off in
three years yeah and then you've got the
next however many years suddenly you get
a seven or eight thousand dollar a month
raise right because i don't have any
house payment you talk about investment
man there's not a lot of investments
that make you that kind of money every
month right yeah and the problem with
the 30-year is they go well john it'll
give me wiggle room you know i got to
have that wiggle room john and you know
wiggle room really means george loves
his wiggle room oh it just yeah it
grinds my years john people say that
because the wiggle room quickly floats
away into oh i bought a new toy or there
was this random expense that came up
when you do a 15 year you go well guess
we have to actually be disciplined
that's just it's going to be on a budget
figure it out and get creative and not
make excuses
and so that's why we do it again it's
not to punish you and if it's 26 percent
of take-home pay we're not going to send
you a letter in the mail chastising
lis it's just a parameter because we
want you to win we want you to not have
a mortgage long term right that's the
difference with our show and the other
get rich quick shows where they go get
as much real estate debt as you can
because that's the path to wealth so
nonsensical so our show is very uh very
counter cultural that way john you know
that you love that
well it's been fun john thanks for
hanging out with me for three hours and
also with you you were forced to but i
think you also enjoyed it i got paid to
do it but since we're best friends
i was pumped to do it oh well it's an
honor and a privilege thank you to my
co-host dr john deloney all the folks in
the booth austin and ben and james and
zach and andrew and josh they're all
back there keeping the show flow in you
america we appreciate you so much we'll
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you